[Music]
hello everyone this is GM Josh Goodell
today I'm gonna be doing a strategic
lecture luckily they didn't give me too
many instructions so I can kind of
lecture on whatever I want in this case
I'm gonna be showing a game of mine I
played at Chicago opened last year
against a very strong Canadian junior
name shirt
shyam love endearing he'd probably hate
me for mispronouncing his name but I
think I got a close enough very talented
kid I'd say I guess I I'd call you a kid
because I remember when he was a kid
actually played him in Toronto open I
think it was 2009 I want to say and you
know he seemed like a kid to me he still
seems like a kid to me but he's college
age I mean he's not he's not that young
but very talented and so I knew he would
and he already beat a GM I think this
tournament so I knew he'd be quite a
dangerous customer so I decided to avoid
theory not because I'm necessarily
worried that he's theoretical but
because I find that people who don't
know I'd say openings are not his
strengths so against people like this
they often don't know the nuances of
positions so when you play Knight f3 or
try to play more quietly sometimes it
works well not because you're trying to
be theoretical but because you're making
it so that they really have to
understand their positions and while
this doesn't always work I'd say at this
game my opening worked very well usually
these days I play d4 but I mean I play
Knight f3 c4 occasionally for if I want
to get crazy 9 f6 c4 e6 g3 I know he
likes to play BOGO he likes to play NIMS
oh so I'm saying you're not gonna play
any of those things
he could play d5 going into a catalan
but it's kind of my territory I know it
pretty well it's not his territory so
again preparation you could see is not
always that deep a lot of it's about I'm
steering it towards what I'm comfortable
with and I know you're not as happy here
that's all it is he played c5
so he was trying to get a hedgehog
position sort of but unfortunately he
was not very precise in the opening and
this kind of backfired of him
so I played Bishop g2 he plays a6
getting a little strange but nothing
outrageous so far right I play Knight c3
so I chose this move for a very simple
purpose why didn't I Castle just does it
for instance yeah b5 is coming right so
I don't know if b5 is a great move maybe
95 works but probably it doesn't do much
but why bother right 93 is a useful move
anyway no reason to overthink it Claes
Queen c7 so he's trying to be very
tricky
what's his idea with Queen c7 what is he
trying to discourage indeed but luckily
he setups a little too cute like it's
kind of okay but it gives me too many
options because he's not putting
pressure on my center he's not making a
threat of d5 ever he's not really doing
all that much so well I don't want to
say objectively it's just poor because
it's probably not I would say it's a
little bit strange so I Castle he plays
Bishop he plays d6 sorry so now what how
to proceed
he still his ideas still discouraging d4
it's trying to be flexible what he's
doing makes some sense but he's gonna
encounter a problem which we'll see yeah
no problem
I can take my time the thing is when
your opponent's playing really weird
risky moves sometimes you want to play
quickly but when they're playing moves
like this which are just signed up
inflexible and waiting for you to play
in the center you can just take your
time there's no reason not to build up
your position so he plays Bishop e7
probably somewhere along these line here
he should have thought about b6 Bishop
d7 and that would have it wasn't the
setup he was aiming for exactly but he'd
get sort of a normal Hedgehog it would
be okay I don't want to say it would be
fantastic for black but his position
would be probably fine but he key plate
here I played Bishop b2 he castled and
now I play d4 so almost always this pawn
has to be captured usually allowing a
move like d5 is really unpleasant so he
takes I played with the knight but here
he has sort of an issue
what is his issue what do you think his
desired setup would be
yeah so what's the problem exactly when
you play a hedgehog type positions you
often have to be precise to get your
hedgehog a lot of people kind of relax a
little bit and again I think he played
the opening a little bit casually but
now he's kind of regretting it because
be six bit should be seven if he played
it earlier he'd probably have a hedgehog
with no problem I'm not saying it's a
great Hedgehog I have my fianchettoed
Bishop which is where I wanted I get an
e4 which is what I want so I get a nice
Hedgehog but it's still a perfectly
normal position it's nothing horrible
for black but here he doesn't really
can't really get his hedgehog now the
question is he played a knight he played
rook e8 the question is can he get a
sort of normal position by playing 96
and I'm going to now turn off the sound
I don't like when the computer yells at
my moves not saying 96 is a horrible
move but I have kind of an annoying move
I can play on them now yeah so if Knight
takes d4 I'm kind of more or less happy
because I can take if here I can play
rook d1 my I'm just very harmonious with
my pieces right but let's say he plays
Bishop d7 AHA this is the problem
because I don't really win any material
most likely maybe I would I don't know
this is pretty weak but the problem is
this pin is just really annoying so
black has to get a very bad pawn
structure and also notice how my pieces
are perfectly positioned whereas blacks
are a lot more passive so that's kind of
the problem black encounters so I move
like 96 not saying it's horrible but it
doesn't really solve blacks problems so
he played rook e8 I play rook c1 has to
be useful right now 96 is not even a
move so he decides on 97 so now what so
you have a position where your pieces
are harmonious things are very
developing nicely you have black a
little bit restricted so how do you how
do you proceed in position like this
what kind of things do you look for
well I would say a very simple answer
would be improving moves yeah right
just improve if you're it's not obvious
how your opponent improves and it is
obvious how you improve that's the
moment where you don't try anything
fancy you just try and prove your moves
let your opponent show you they can
improve but the key is to choose
improving moves which don't allow your
opponent to free themselves if you allow
them to have an easy idea after an
improving move you probably want to wait
on that one and choose other ones first
so to give you an example
efore might be a perfectly okay move
here I would not quit any guesses as to
why that would be
it does and it's something which I don't
want to do until I have to now I move
like b6 is probably not playable to the
e5 sometimes black can sack this
exchange by the way and it's not so bad
here looks a little dubious but let's
say black plays ro p8 next b6 next bit
should be 7 ok it's a little slow but
black gets development finished right
this is not what I want so I'd rather
play an improving move that doesn't
allow it at all because of the bishop
open like this if black tries rook b8 b
6 I have a very simple answer those but
anyway first like what do you think I
play it what's a simple improving move
where do out what pieces are not ideally
placed yet mm-hmm okay so where do I
want this rook okay where do I want the
Queen okay I opted for d2 but this is
the point he played Knight a fade which
is a little bit sad but the idea is that
if he tries rook b8 for example I play
here and black plays here there's a very
problematic move indeed and you actually
just lose material because I have to
take and then your rooks gonna hang so
black doesn't even get to finish the
relevant that way so he opted for Knight
f8 and Bishop d7 so he's kind of
finished his development but what's the
problem
would you say that not enough aid is a
ideally placed piece not particularly
active it's okay i improve how do you
improve now
yep there's no reason not to play the
Pondy for the thing is and this is one
of those tough decisions at least for me
this is always difficult I never really
want to play you for because I like my
bishop I'd like to have an open bishop
but the fact is eventually you got a
push you have to expand that's the whole
idea so eventually you do want to play a
move like a floor and I felt like here
my pieces were improving almost as much
as they can so it's as good a time as
any to play it so black played Knight g6
so again find a piece to improve what
piece is not ideal it's very difficult
once you have pieces that all look kind
of nice then you have to come up with an
idea usually before your opponent sorts
out their mess
Bishop a3 is definitely a move that
comes to mind I don't think I played it
yet oh no I did I thought I played 92
first but no I played this your way
through first so it happens when you get
older you know I just don't remember any
of your games no I I thought I played 92
first but Bishop a3 first so I'm trying
to target this week pump make it feel a
little less happy about its life so
black played rook t8
so now what how'd you get it doesn't act
e-6 yes so he plays back yeah I mean
Bishop Bishop c6 was what I kind of
expected but part of the problem is that
now let's say I mean 93 is a normal
improving move right really clamping
down on the center the problem is that
now 95 is still kind of in the air right
and it's sort of an annoying move so
again I don't know if this is actually
the best way to continue this was part
of the game I wasn't sure about but it
seemed like a natural way to build so
black played Knight here and I have to
admit this move kind of tempted me so I
played this rook f8 rook a fade is
definitely a slightly sad move but at
the same time black needs a way to try
to defend pieces right so after rook f8
the advantage at least is that this
knight can draw back to it but this is
where I kind of decided to be a little
bit sneaky played this move so what is
the purpose of this move
see five do I want to let my opponent
out know I'm a little crazy but maybe
not that crazy
maybe so there are some tactical points
for example beasts if after b6 I
couldn't do anything my move would look
pretty silly but there's a tactical
problem with b6 because yeah black could
play this move I'd feel very stupid so
try to target blacks weaknesses what is
weak now hmm so how can you target it
yeah it's a weird looking move but
there's a problem now because you're
attacking this pawn and the only logical
way to defend it would be 97 but this
move also has a problem so that's kind
of the point but I would say and I have
to I mean I can tell you that I
certainly was you have to be very very
careful about moves like that a4 because
they you can often give up any advantage
you have if you get too concrete too
early moves like this are weird it
doesn't mean they're bad but it means
that if you play this at the wrong time
it can just be a stupid move it can just
be your opponent does something to
counter it and then your knight feels
stupid or they get in b5 or something
happens but on occasion when you build
up your position you do have some kind
of concrete move like this to greater
increase to increase your advantage even
more I don't know if this is actually
best I mean I thought that actually in
this position black might try going back
a bit or not and now I might have gone
back and it seems silly but what have I
lost I repeated moves once it happens
all the time and then I maybe find
something else I was thinking about
taking this pawn but I thought that this
was not so clear this endgame here takes
takes takes my pawns get kind of broken
up black gets a lot of activity either
with rook in maybe roof d4 I don't know
or maybe 95 is also possible I just
wasn't sure maybe this is okay for me
actually but I don't know it was a
little tough for me to say but okay I
was looking at it I'm not saying I
wouldn't have taken on d6 but here's the
thing if they play Bishop d7 at least
you
can go back you haven't lost anything
right if they don't and he didn't now I
can build my position even further with
which move when you play move like mad
eh for you usually have something
specific in mind right you're not just
gonna be exactly you have to be careful
you put you're not an a4 you better have
a follow-up if you just play a four then
you feel kind of foolish right yeah and
I think this move he missed cuz here he
got into a really deep thing because
again he thought I was really focused on
the beat the d6 square but he didn't see
that my idea was to sneak out to be four
and now black has a serious problem
because Bishop a5 is coming and b6 still
runs into queen d4 and I just win this
pawn so again moves ideas like this are
very rare you usually don't get to play
them but the reason why is because
usually black has well placed pieces
black has pawn here night here Bishop
here of course you're not gonna be able
to do this then but when your opponent
has worse than normal pieces when
they're stuck when they're kind of
stuffed when their pieces are on the
back rank that's when you look for
concrete ideas because often tactical
ideas that normally don't work can work
and again I'm not even sure that what I
do is correct
but it will ended up being justified a
little bit and the main reason is
because black just has very poor pieces
so tactical ideas are more likely to
work so black played back I went to be
safe I've played f4 the reason I played
that for anyone know I hated to yell at
you after you played out for but now
that I played it it's fine
exactly I thought that 95 to c6 was an
easy way back I didn't want that night
on g6 to get back in the game and he
can't stop night to be 6 if b5 I take it
and all of a sudden this night is pretty
bad right
maybe black could think about sacking
the exchange first of all I could take
the night maybe but probably I just take
this but I highly doubt this is enough
oops I mean my Kings not quite open
enough flex pieces are still weird
probably not worth an exchange maybe I
play 9c for now covering all the squares
I don't know I don't really believe in
blacks blue shirt but it was something I
had to consider but black played here so
yeah and you and you'll notice this
about like when people have really tough
positions they're forced to play ugly
moves and at least psychologically even
if ugly moves are the best it's hard for
us to play we don't want to play moves
like this but sometimes it's necessary
so 96 and at f8 but I thought a long
time here and I couldn't really find a
way to punish black blacks gonna play 97
next I wasn't really sure what to do it
looks like I made huge progress right I
sunk a nitin to b6 how could that
possibly be bad but the problem is that
well what do I do afterwards what
happens when black puts the 97 do I want
to trade pieces why not
exactly but I almost have to otherwise I
end up just backtracking with all my
guys so I chose King H one I don't know
if King each ones the most precise maybe
I should just launch but okay
I chose King H one I'm glad I actually
played the move on the screen that I
said this time it would be embarrassing
of her I forgot everything but this I
remember 97 and I made a really
difficult decision here I'm not
convinced it's a bad one but it was very
difficult what do I do
it looks very anti positional let me
give you that hints and I'm still not
sure it's good computer I recall does
not like it but that doesn't always
convince me in positions like this ah f5
is definitely a Thai positional you got
that mark down but I'm not sure it does
much it's that you're allowing 95 you're
allowing Bishop g5 it's probably too
much that's interesting but I'm never
ever gonna take so hmm
yeah I'm taking the worst piece on the
planet but there's a method to my
madness
why am i taking that easy
actually f5 can come into play but it
comes into play way way way later it's
more to do with how is black ever and I
do mean ever gonna get Connor play now
blacks only source of counter play in in
these types of head trunk positions are
what two moves be five or d5 good luck
playing defy of a lot of Bishop buddy
and that's kind of my idea it seems
silly because like what is black gonna
do anyway and again I'm not totally sure
this is the right decision but this was
kind of my thinking that okay I take the
bishop I get rid of black horse piece
but how is black ever gonna get true
counter play if black ever opens the
position opens the light scores with b5
or d5 I'm pretty happy I have my two
bishops this is something which like the
problem is when we're young we get the
bad bishop drilled into us so bad or
when we first start out we're like all
these positions you have a terrible
Bishop you never ever take the bad
bishop but close positions and
positional chess is a lot more nuanced
there are so many positions where you
actually do want to take the bad bishop
because in the future they're gonna want
that bishop how many times do you see
like you take a bad French bishop on c8
and all of a sudden East six is super
weak and can't be defended happens all
the time so there are many moments where
getting rid of a bad bishop is not as
bad as you would think I don't know if
this is exactly one of these situations
but I can tell you that not having the
two bishops or rather having the two
bishops for me was a really nice thing
later in the game so I played queen bee
- again I'm not sure about the precision
of these moves but I was just trying to
you know maneuver my pieces a little bit
black played Bishop F eights
I played back because my bishop no
longer is useful on a5 Brett I pinned
the knight congratulations to me but not
really doing a whole lot I remember I
really wanted to set up Knight d5 but I
could never get it to work because black
can always play b6 on me so so it goes
I play back black plays 95 I play Queen
c2 so why am I going to see - yeah I
want to play b4 and so I'm fixing my
queen
that's the nice thing when you have kind
of a positional edge that's not going
anywhere you can take your time you can
move back and forth
I wanted my my idea by the way was to
advance on the Queen side to push my
Queen side pawns and my general thinking
was that without that bishop he's gonna
have our time stopping this plan and
creating conically so black played Queen
b8 I played before I played a4 and this
was that moment where and you always
come to this no matter how strong your
opponent is when they're playing a
passive the position when they're
defending there's always one moment
where they lash out incorrectly they
they don't like their to be passive no
one likes to just sit there I don't care
how solid a pert opponent you're playing
no one likes to just sit there and there
are the thing is you shouldn't almost
ever sit there the whole game and most
players know this that if you sit the
whole game eventually your opponent's
gonna beat you but there are positions
where you have to at least be patient
and in this position black should really
not try to do a whole lot one
interesting idea was maybe trying a five
looks a little strange but the idea
would be that now you at least secure
this square I don't know if this is
actually that good for black but okay
black slit in the game right and part of
it also was I was fairly sure he was
gonna play b5 here sometimes you can see
it in their eyes
you just know he hated leaving his
pieces so BAM he played it very quickly
he didn't have tons of time either I
can't say I had tons like this position
is as nice as it looked it was actually
difficult to play because all my pieces
look so good you have to figure out what
to do with them right sometimes those
are the toughest ones to play but why
was I happy to see b5 he's trying to get
counter playing he's breaking a little
bit what is the problem with the move b5
ah it's kind of hard to do that yeah
very simple now when I look at things
like this you have to realize the power
in a five I'm not gonna Queen that guy
anytime soon
but it's kind of like a reserve like you
save it for later
you know leftover piece of cake you put
it in the fridge you can get it any time
you want but the whole point is that
it's it's this something that's always
there it's always an advantage I'm gonna
have now if I'm careless and allow black
to say play 96 and get b4 is a weakness
which is definitely something that can
happen then maybe it'll backfire but the
whole point is that you kind of give
yourself something for later and that's
part of what strong positional chess is
you kind of collect advantages little by
little so I have the two bishops that
was one advantage I collected right the
next one is this past pawn on 85 so the
more of these little advantages I
collect the harder it's gonna be for
black to hold the position down now one
of those things is not gonna be bit
fatal by itself right you usually need
more than one advantage to win a game
but you collect all right past a pawn
you collect all right two bishops you
don't have your LightSquared Bishop you
collect and you collect and eventually
the pressure just increases and you'll
see how this happens so black played
Knight a6 and they'll be my guess that
black sought okay I have before the
knight blocks the pawn anyway but my
thinking was a little different it was
just that okay you have I have a past a
pawn now your be pawn might become week
later you know but mostly it's just I
have this for later in the game you now
have this pawn to worry about you can't
just abandon it anytime now I do have to
worry about d5 but the nice thing for d5
of course I I do have it well covered
right
it opens up my bishop so black has to be
careful with d5
so I played Queen B to not wanting to
allow it black played rook c8 and I
don't know here here maybe I play it a
little too simplistic I decided that the
actual simplest way for me to try to
convert this advantage was actually to
trade off the rooks I thought that if I
trade off all the rooks Black's gonna
have a harder time
holding down the queenside that was my
thinking again I'm not sure it's correct
this was maybe a position where I could
have tried something else maybe I could
have played I don't know even just like
h3 quick King age to improving my King
just really taking my time I had lots of
different options but again I decided on
this I wasn't super unhappy with him
black played Knight f6 so I continued
with my idea
I take play Roxy won again maybe not the
best choice yeah so black played 98 here
which i think was a little too
pessimistic if ever there was a time to
try d5 it was now
now after takes I think that I end up in
a better end game so yeah the problem
here was that f7 is quite weak right now
not to mention a pond so black just
plays here for instance pretty sure I
can take play a six and this in between
these two weaknesses it's gonna be very
difficult to play as black so you can
see why the a pawn comes in handy right
that guy is really nasty right now so
but this move was kind of clever I think
I may have missed this during the game
and I have to move back because now if
Queen c6 I think the problem was this
move and somehow I'm not coordinated
kind of weird right I don't know but I
didn't see all this during the game I
will admit this quite freely and now you
can take and again promising for white
but maybe not winning you know but hey
who says I'm even winning here in any
case my opponent played backwards I took
and played here very methodical I don't
even mind the endgame I don't feel like
my King's better than blacks right and
in the endgame I can slowly push this
pawn bring my King to the center I'm not
saying the endgame again is a complete
win but the endgame is gonna be really
unpleasant between the two bishops b5
and the power on a5 that was my thinking
make sense
it's a black plate here I played h4
again just trying to improve my King a
little bit I don't like my King stuck
without any moves to go to right black
plate 97 so what move do you think's
coming so here's my question should
black we playing for d5 what is what is
this question kind of hinge on because
these are the toughest moments to decide
whether to play a move like d5 or not
for some players probably for my
opponent it was automatic I don't want
to sit here forever of course I'm gonna
play you fun the same thinking that made
him play d5 and do we think b5 was a
good move probably not so much right so
the question is is he correct and
thinking d5 is what he should be playing
for but here's our question and it was
the same question with b5 is it better
to wait or to play d5 waiting isn't
always the worst strategy how do you
decide whether to wait or whether to
push whether to try to create a mess
whether to try to just hold back yeah
it's one of the toughest decisions to
make but I think that unlike in the
position where he plays b5 which kind of
gives me a clear position allege I do
not think d5 does this d5 is a risky
move in that you might lose a pawn and
that you might you know open up my
Bishop a little bit but you're creating
a weakness on b4 that you can possibly
attack you're opening up the position
and keep in mind White's king is not
perfect here you might get kind of play
against white king I think that even
though it didn't necessarily work out
for him
playing for d5 was absolutely the right
decision because if you sit here I bet I
have so many improving moves I can play
Queen t3 I can play King Age 2 I can
improve my bishop I can play for f5 an
idea you had before which now that
certainly does not look stupid you know
if you give me unlimited moves here I
have a lot of improvements to play and
keep in mind if I get in for
improvements and then try to initiate
complications you might have a much
harder time defending
so I think he was absolutely justified
in his decision to play for d5 here but
notice how I don't think he should have
played B 5 because b5 simply gave me
that past pawn on a5 that's a concrete
problem so that's a good way to kind of
figure it out first of all can my
opponent do a lot if I do nothing if the
answer is yes you probably shouldn't be
doing nothing then you're just giving
them free moves to improve ask yourself
if time is a factor
ask yourself if I play this lashing out
move do they have a perm do they get a
permanent weakness to work with do they
get a permanent strength does it you
know what are the changes that happen in
the position it's one of the hardest
things to do in chess I mean I'm sure if
I were black in this position I would
have made all sorts of bad decisions
it's just really really difficult but
the key is you have to be very
disciplined and pick your moments well
is this a moment I lash out is this a
moment I get counterplay or is this a
moment I need to be patient and the same
goes when you're playing the offense is
this a moment where I want to be just be
methodical trade Queens get my queen on
the C file is this a moment where I
should be playing quickly because my
opponents gonna regroup is this a moment
where my opponent has no improving moves
and then you play slowly so these are
the ways you think about these positions
at least for me so I played Queen t3
trying to keep a lid on d5 and black
does indeed play d5 so the question is
how do you react to such a move you act
you think you're prepared for it you're
ready for it
but it comes quite possible Queen t4
would have been a pretty good move I
think I didn't play that but uh I think
may have been a nice move I ended up
playing something else I played a knife
here I wanted the pawn defended by two
pieces so that my Queen was free
essentially was my thinking I don't know
if it was correct I mean Queen t4 has a
lot of Merit too but yeah if you try to
take right away the problem is now
you're really opening up the position
but you're opening up your own King as
well so for example I think the idea was
actually just to start taking
let me see if I got this right yeah if
you trade everything it's gonna be bad
but I think actually you could just take
care because this pawn is pinned as well
right so it takes takes and this is
hanging and I just wasn't sure you have
to be careful about your own King it's a
little messy this is kind of example of
a line you don't want but it's important
you're prepared for deeper right so I
played here this was my prepared move
black played Queen e8 so now what do I
want to take on d5
it is a pawn up for offer mm-hmm so if I
play here for example
takes with night so now this guy is
under heavy threat yeah so I don't have
to take this but if I don't then black
certainly made progress right so if I
take Queen come see - I don't know you
could I've seen it happen you can end up
worse in positions like this I've
certainly done it myself and it looks
because you think I'm winning upon I
finally it's important not to create a
narrative for yourself like I've been
grinding my opponent out and now I win
upon it makes perfect sense you have to
make sure this is your moment if you
take this palm prematurely allow Queenie
to I mean who knows right
and again just an example of something I
don't want but again I don't think I
have to be in a rush to take right so I
could have played king h2 was maybe an
interesting move improving but I chose a
different improving move Bishop c3 again
just trying to improve my pieces a
little by little again I wasn't sure
about this move because sometimes if
takes takes Knight d5 I'm kind of
putting it on pre forget exactly what my
idea was I think because I'm threatening
this pawn I get an a tempo and I think I
was gonna use that tempo but King h2
might have been a little wiser I don't
know it ended up being okay but black
played h6 so the question is now how do
i improve I could play him with a king
h2 still but I was actually very happy
with what I did
I saw h6 and I was happy to see h6 so
the question is what approach can I take
now
g4 that's a bit reckless
I mean g4 I mean now maybe takes in here
I don't know man it's a lot of stuff
loose some people are perfectly fine
moving all the pawns approach that came
really nearly you know I'm not one of
those people but I also think that it's
objectively risky and I'm not sure what
you're accomplishing either if you get
in G v g6 I could kind of be with you
but I don't know if it's gonna happen
for you
maybe guessing was the problem
but I was thinking this is one of the
thoughts I had during this position and
again it just I'm not saying these are
all correct thoughts and these fit again
for me these are complicated positions I
am not 100% sure of myself always but
one of my thoughts was that you know
what I'm really annoyed the blacks King
is safe and mine is not I would rather
we both have Kings that are not ideal
because again my main goal was I felt
like if I could trade Queens my winning
chances will be really good but it's
kind of hard to force that if your
opponent doesn't want to so what I'd
like is at least have my opponents King
be a little weak also so how can I make
it so that maybe my opponent's King
becomes a little bit weaker h5 is
possible but you have to be very careful
imagine you get hit by f5 at the wrong
moment and then this guy hangs right got
to be very careful
that's what I did so what's the main
idea what's your threat
well let me just give you an example
let's say black goes plays King
somewhere right just to show you and I
take what is the difference between this
and our previous position
what has happened that's been in White's
favor yes this king is no longer clearly
a strength or clearly safe blacks king
is also open you go up in this diagonal
there's this guy always hanging I might
get a temple move on this pawn all of a
sudden blacks King is not comfortable
doesn't mean my Kings more comfortable
but I think blacks is less comfortable
and to me that makes blacks life a lot
harder you see what I mean so that was
my main goal with that five I wanted
black to have to think about what to do
with that King so black took on e4 and
took here which is logical right however
this was a bit of a windfall for me what
happened to my pieces that was so good
my Bishop's much more active the
positions wide open and I kind of like
that because exactly so again I wasn't a
hundred percent sure but I felt like
this was clearly an improvement to my
position and notice how this pawn could
actually be kind of annoying if black
could put this pawn back here and play
g6 Bishop g7 might be a little bit
annoying for me of course he has to
watch out for Queen d4 but just in
general I like having the pawn here when
I have the light but light square bishop
may be not a huge deal but I was kind of
happy with it so black played check in
here now here I'm not saying what I
found was amazing but I found something
very clever here I basically stole a
temple
I love stealing Tempe it's great it's
like you're stealing minutes first of
all what is black maybe threatening
possibly
I don't know if it does a lot but I
don't want to allow it who wants to
allow Queen x3 that's ridiculous
so originally I was thinking Oh Josh
just play King age 2 but I could not
help myself I found what I thought was
super clever and again I'm not a hundred
percent sure it's best but it worked out
quite nicely actually especially
considering my opponent was in time
trouble and wanted to stick to simple or
moves
so I'll give you a hint I wanted to play
Bishop a5 also but then queen c6 check
and I couldn't find anything better
really than King h2 or going back and I
don't know I didn't want to play king h2
for some reason I'm forgetting now but I
thought because it allows my d5 yeah so
after Bishop f5 Queen c6 I just have to
go back I didn't like that Queen f3 I
didn't want to allow Queen h3 yeah again
I'm not 100% sure it's a killer but what
I don't want to do with it I'm too lazy
you'll notice laziness is a very common
feature of GM's we see Queen h3 we don't
care if it's good we just don't want to
bother with it what's the point how do
you steal time
well Bishop a5 and Quincy 6 but
yeah but it's not random it's clear the
king is worse on h8 then on g8 right
now Queen d8 with tempo f7 pawn can hang
so it's clearly a worse version right
maybe 25 I wouldn't push it it's a very
wick keep in mind it's probably not even
clearly the best move but again I like
to steal a little Tempe right you never
know when that one Tempe is gonna really
come in handy at one tempo is really
gonna come in handy and by the way it
does black I play kg - I think yeah I
wanted to go towards the center because
I'm preparing for the endgame right so
black played here so black wants Connor
played desperately and I do not care to
allow it so what do I play yeah I found
something slightly more active Queen f3
would be kind of sneaky this is a little
bit more direct but the same idea
queen of five is a monster threat right
but I wanted to play a more active move
while threatening
so now I'm threatening Queen f5 which is
kind of embarrassing because it's just
me isn't it convenient to have the Queen
here and if black goes back I can always
play Queen f5 Queen f6 and that's also
gonna be over so what does black have to
play none of them give me my endgame and
then game was my favourite phase of this
yeah so black took with the pawn taking
with the Knights possible but you allow
Bishop to b7 with tempo it's a little
hard to do that and also this King is
really bad right in the endgame my king
is very happy because I'm much closer so
black took but this is also kind of a
bad pawn weakness so how do you convert
this endgame what are the steps because
I think objectively the same game should
be just lost Black's has a bad past ruck
sure I have that beauty on a5 I have the
two bishops in a wide open position and
blacks more passive there's no way it
should not be winning first paralysis
paralysis is a very important technique
I chose this one because I don't want
this night moving at all I want it to
have no dreams of ever moving so black
plays here what's next
lock him down no pushing of the palms
for you
I want the pawn stuck on those squares
the same color as his bishop right an
added bonus that these pawns can never
ever get attacked right if I Allah if I
play King f3 not saying this would be a
horrible move but now black plays h5 oh
my king can't move see that lock them
down so King here prove my king
g4 logical right so here black plays g6
which was a little bit impatient but at
the same time what is black gonna do if
black just sits eventually I will be
able to win although sitting would have
lasted longest if he tries this what it
was my plan because that's the thing you
have to see all the active moves right
if you miss a move like 95 you can
really pay for it but luckily I did see
it
this should be sevens kind of clever but
the problem is I think it's too clever
first of all you're winning a side on
the worst side of the pond and the worst
side of the board usually not the best
idea but also after I take and take I
think we're just liquidating so we end
up just trading all the pawns this is
not what you want too clever too clever
come on you guys can be simple remember
the oh I don't know if I told you guys
about the Indiana Jones thing no never
mind forget it wrong audience wrong on
answer I was explaining this to a
student that you want to choose the
golden cup but sometimes you have to
choose the Carpenters Cup the the more
direct the not as pretty one but it's
works just fine if you haven't seen the
movie I'm just talking to air but it's
okay a few people will laugh an audience
or at least they'll groan
simple direct
so Bishop d5 is possible but this is
actually quite simple so the point is
that now if you try to take this pawn I
just take
yeah
if Knight takes nice
simple right you don't have to get too
fancy about it but you have to make sure
you see it and the problem is 95 Bishop
d2 there's nothing better than going
back there's no way to actually activate
so it's kind of a clever little trick
yeah and if you take with the bishop I
think I'm just super super boring about
it and I just take take and play a6 and
it's that extra piece I should be able
to win keep in mind that I do not have
to allow black to liquidate all these
pawns like if black plays here the key
is that I'm not there is no way I am
allowing pawn takes pawn right you have
to be careful but I do this there's no
h5 for you I'd go here so you know black
goes here I just parked this guy and
kind of laughs a little bit I'm gonna go
here pretty easy win but you have to be
very careful if you allow if you allow
the pawns thing liquidated at the wrong
moment and could go very badly black
played here next I say no more than 85
take take King f8 black has no moves so
how do I finish the game I play this
first I didn't mean to go that far ahead
but shouldn't give away anything so
here's the key I thought a little while
here to make sure I found the proper way
to finish it off so how do you finish it
off allowing zero counter play and I do
mean zero the number zero by the way
notice how I collected another weakness
right you have this strength two bishops
parallel process weakness when you add
up a lot of weaknesses the wind tends to
be much easier so it's an important
thing to kind of note as the game goes
it's easy to forget about weaknesses but
my thinking was very simple I want to
improve my night on c2 if I prove that
night I think the game is over
but for now what's the problem yep
so I picked my piece that I thought
wasn't doing all that much and that's
the piece I want to use what piece do
you think that is mm-hmm again black has
no moves right kh7 what can black do
next move I just move my knight and then
I'm just gonna win the b5 pawn Knight a
three Knight takes d5 or even takes a6
first takes b5 the game is over red
black played this and then I actually
found a different way even faster
black gave me another weakness I'm happy
to use it and here he just gave up it
was over it's easy to kind of but it's
easy to see like I move like 93 you can
just make your opponent resign because
now it's like well I can't move or do
anything right so again I mean games
like this don't occur all the time where
you kind of are able to get a dominating
position like this it's something which
you know only happens now and then and
you want to savor these moments when you
can so what I do is I just lecture about
him endlessly but but I would say the
main thing to remember from this is like
the patience thing no doubt for both
myself and my opponent patience was an
important commodity that's you know for
him there are moments where he could
have been more patient then there are
moments where he lashed out with d5
which he should have but then his
position kind of fell apart around him
when he didn't play the most accurate
way and from my perspective the other
one was the collecting of advantages and
this is something I'd say again GM's are
kind of known for doing and part of its
just keep always having chess is kind of
become a very concrete game where it's
all about alright you go here I go here
there are concrete things here the
doubled pawns aren't is meaningful and
this is all good stuff this is all true
but I would say that what people often
forget about is there are still
advantages which work in the long term
you may have doubled pawns on aren't
weak now but if you're not careful down
the road they can become weak right so
what I'd say what happened here was I
just collected little advantages to
bishops slight advantage that I have
permanently not going anywhere right
this past pawn slight advantage not
going anywhere and I slowly collected
advantages until here you can see all
the advantages very plainly to bishops
better pieces right Black's
tied down past pawn weakness when you
collect enough advantages the position
can just play itself and you see how you
have this many weaknesses that you just
can't hold it no matter how skilled you
are you could defend like Geary or like
karyakin you're not gonna hold a
position like this because it's just too
many weaknesses so one of the positional
strategies that you guys can use is
sometimes again don't think in terms of
can I use it now but so think of in
terms of what advantages can I collect
for later in the game
which I can then cash in on in the
endgame or later in the middle game
[Music]